ah yes ah yes say my Santa Claus
I think I'm Santa Claus so what would
Santa Claus do in a situation like this
I would steal all their [ __ ] boom
that's my bicycle this is my teeny santa
needs gifts too what else do we need
Christmas pudding all year that's my
Christmas pudding no no no no no what
else
Oh money 20 money money money money
money money money so much money oh my
god there's a painting there this
ugly-ass painting yes I mean it's
probably worth a fortune dude okay oh
god they're coming oh god they're coming
I've got a bit of height I better hide
in the closet thank God oh my god Tom
Cruise Tom Cruise stop stop Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise is bidding the [ __ ] out of me
ah run run run run run run rod I'm sorry
who would beat up Santa whoo-hoo I'm an
everyday thief thief no I'm Sam I'm
Santa was reverse gifting I was gift
reversing have you never heard of that
you take [ __ ] from people it's great
hey Tom it's me I got all your [ __ ] Tom
Tom doesn't know what to do I got all
your [ __ ] what you got a do about it
[ __ ] Wow in your face Tom Cruise in
your face oh my god that was amazing